j'estime que le sénat doit être le
rempart des collectivités locales et en
particulier des collectivités locales
menthe et nicaise puisque c'est à la
martinique que je suis candidat parce
que ces collectivités locales sont elles
mêmes le rempart de notre population
quelle que soit la difficulté dans
laquelle se trouve un administré son
premier contact c'est le maire et qu'est
ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui c'est que
les collectivités locales sont soumises
à énormément de pression on attendait
énormément de voir énormément de
prérogatives leur sont délégués sans les
moyens voire même avec des moyens
existants qui sont en baisse voire en
suppression j'ai l'exemple de la baisse
de la dgf
j'ai l'exemple de la suppression des
contrats aidés alors qu'il faut
absolument qu une voix forte déterminée
puisse aller dire au sinaï il faut qu'il
retrouve son rôle le plus que jamais de
rempart des collectivités locales